Hello my name is soccer my love I am an
international chess master and I am
here because today I am going to play
prince tactics and for you and of course it is a
very special day because as you can hear
I am speaking Spanish for the first
time
[Music]
and well let's go with  tactic versus as
always something better for me is effort
first we play the brandon mode in this
mode you can get easy
intermediate and difficult exercises and clarified let's
let's go
here we have
[Music]
a fork efe 6
and here what happens
what happens on horseback capable of six ladies
per  the ef 5
good well it lasts 16 it
was a mistake and I don't understand why rook
corp now and efficient of course and f8 and here
we are going to get we are going to win a rook
rook for us
so
we have a rook rook
checkmate in a porsche play
give me
too  6
a fork again yes well I am very
happy
happy as a worm because it is going
well
and therefore it is to put the sea 4
so for efe five because we have a
hall mate for  eight and rook for efe eight
that's good and here we have a pin
because if he plays the bishop of 7 we have a queen
for four very nice
phil for and bishop for a 8 totally
won
totally everything is for efe actors for
efe 7
[Music]
why not because  mother and
because I don't understand
it no no no no no they haven't taken care of you, be
careful
4 for
good
because I want a checkmate at 22
rf 8
4 to 2
how nice very nice
bodies of 8 x
very easy 110 5 I guess
here
m4  we have a pin but to h3 queen
because he feels and we lost a bishop
so finally for the first first
to me
the 3rd march
I don't know that pure sebastian hurry up but
I'm going to do all of 8 not
difficult
and here either I don't know what to do or of course
everything for one like me for us f3 and
give me
nothing happens right 2
nothing happens nothing happens
and of course we don't have we don't have a lot of
time f4 checkmate and rook by
March 3, 5 checkmate rook by 6
fork for us  queen of 4 we have
again we don't have  s we don't have time
knight f8 the queen is trapped behind she
has swallowed she hasn't been burned by
[Music] he
set 6 for them to kill a move will end
I'm very stressed because we don't have
much time king for the 4 what we are going to
do what we are going  to do here
tower 7 and phone 30 for three horses
for five to the filter 16 and give me
four to have to get the bull
of 25
and well we already have a little more time a
little more time and it is difficult
phil for efe two because  not to phil for
effects
his eyes we have 9 seconds also for
h 6 finally for efe 6 also for the lady
4 to win camera and six envelopes for
us again
5 and 5 1 no 345 mayaya rhyme and lose
I lost
[Music]
[  Applause]
how good I'm actually I'm very
happy for that
because it wasn't that impressive but it
wasn't bad either and well maybe you can
beat me let me know how it went in the
comments and as always thank you very
much for the attention and we  see in
the p  next
[Music]